exercice de pédagogie pour jean castex
comme au printemps pour les mesures de
confinement le premier ministre a
précisé la mise en application des
restrictions annoncées la veille par
emmanuel macron jean castex est
notamment revenu sur le détail du
couvre-feu imposé entre 21h et 6h en ile
de france et dans huit métropoles qui
entre en vigueur dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi face aux progrès de
l'épidémie le gouvernement a également
rétabli l'état d'urgence sanitaire
une situation qui élargit certaine
mesure à l'ensemble du territoire
national des mesures générales
s'appliqueront partout puisque tout le
territoire national sera désormais
placée en état d'urgence sanitaire
ces règles qui s'appliqueront partout
sont les suivantes toutes les fêtes
privées comme les mariages ou les
soirées étudiantes qui se tiennent dans
des salles des fêtes dans des salles
polyvalentes ou tout autre établissement
recevant du public seront interdites
tous les restaurants de france
impliqueront le protocole sanitaire qui
a été récemment renforcées et prévoient
notamment la limitation à 6 du nombre de
clients par table et l'enregistrement du
nom des clients pour faciliter le
contact racing dans tous les lieux
vous êtes assis comme les cinémas à les
stades les cirques où les salles de
conférence
la règle d'un siège sur deux devra
s'appliquer
gérald darmanin a détaillé le dispositif
de contrôle mis en place par le
ministère de l'intérieur
douze mille fonctionnaires de police et
de gendarmerie seront mobilisés pour
faire respecter le couvre-feu dans les
zones concernées
en cas d'infraction restrictions les
forces de l'ordre pourront verbaliser
comme lors de la période du confinement
sanctions qui sont appliquées au moment
où les gens ne respectent pas d
interdiction de ce couvre-feu de 21h à
6h qui ne s'applique que dans les zones
évoquées par monsieur le premier
ministre
une amende de 135 euros ce vers la même
amende que pendant le confinement et si
jamais il devait y avoir réitération
cédant cible de trois fois les policiers
ou les gendarmes arrivent à confondre
une personne qui par trois fois
rhodes ou ne respecte pas ces règles
d'interdiction six mois d'emprisonnement
possible et 3750 euros d'amendé
l'ensemble des mesures sanitaires entre
en vigueur pour une durée de quatre
semaines et pourrait s'étendre au moins
jusqu'à la fin du mois de novembre
si le parlement donne son aval à une
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire